The dark side of the force is a pathway
to many abilities some consider to be
unnatural is it possible to learn this
power? Not from a Jedi.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Happy
New Year is I'm posting this video this
is going to be my Mandalorian season 2 top 10 predictions video if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos I will be doing
Mandalorian videos during the break
they've already announced when season 2
episodes are going to start so we're not
going to have to wait too long before we
get season 2 they're also finally
selling baby Yoda merch so we'll do a
giveaway for that all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your predictions about season 2 on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this big spoiler warning for
everything that happened on the
mandalorian season 1 as we go through
our top 10 here so starting with number
10 they won't find more members of
Yoda's race I think this is a pretty
easy prediction to make the whole idea
of the armorer;s mission that she tasked
him with is that he's supposed to go
find his people and if you know anything
about the way George Lucas treated the
Yoda character so protectively actively
seeking to prevent other people inside
Star Wars and Lucasfilm the TV shows the
books the movies the video games from
creating any new backstory for the Yoda
character anytime anyone got even close
to saying what planet Yoda came from or
who his parents were what his childhood
was like in the Jedi Order he would drop
the banhammer hard no explaining Yoda
yes George Lucas did sell Lucasfilm and
the rights to Star Wars to Disney so
technically he doesn't control it
anymore since 2012 but all the current
people making Star Wars like you know
Dave Filoni Jon Favreau worship at the
feet of George Lucas so at least they
aren't going to trample on his wishes and
just completely explain every last
detail about Yoda in a way that George
Lucas never wanted to see on screen
there was a joke that George Lucas did
tell though about Yoda during the
commentaries for the blu-ray editions a
couple years ago he called Yoda the
illegitimate child of Kermit and Miss
Piggy but obviously that's him just
joking number 9 even though they might
not find all of Yoda's race they will
probably get information on the planet
that baby Yoda himself came from which
might not necessarily be the original
homeworld of Yoda's race just a planet
that baby Yoda is believed to have been
born on he's about 50 years old that
means he was born around the same time
the Anakin Skywalker was born before the
events of Phantom Menace theory craft
all you want about the possible
connection between two powerful force
beings like that be
born in such close proximity to each
other but we really don't know enough
about Yoda's race to know what it's like
when they give birth their amphibious
looking creatures they could give birth
like most warm-blooded mammals but they
could also be hatched from eggs like
frogs lay eggs
But even then, that's just trading on a lot of offhanded remarks
that George Lucas
makes calling Yoda a frog like creature
finding the planet that he came from
though is the first major step in
finding the ancestral home of Yoda's
race but I think finding their ancestral
home planet is something that's probably
going to take the entire run of the series
if they ever find it
it'd be like treasure hunters finally
the lost city of gold in the second
season of a TV show that's not something
you do right away number 8 baby Oda
still won't speak with words like Yoda
spoke with right now he just garbles and
coos like a human baby it's not clear if
he's even capable of speaking words and
just chooses not to because he is 50
years old
even if he's a baby he's had much more
time to learn how to communicate through
body language than a human baby would at
the same level of biological development
another really easy prediction to make
is that he's probably not going to grow a
lot physically larger I think part of
the idea and doing a character like
someone from Yoda's race who ages and
physically matures so slowly is that if
the mandalorian series runs furred like
five seasons baby Yoda will physically
stay a little baby for the entire run of
the series but number seven follow up he
will learn and developmentally in as a
force user a lot so it's not like he's
completely frozen developmentally his
ability to use the force in different
ways will get more fine-tuned and when
he does choose to Hulk out in moments of
great distress like when he lashes out
an anger to protect the Mandalorian like
force choking cardoon those types of
abilities he manifests will get bigger
and bigger crazier and crazier and just
cooler to watch on screen right now
though as far as we can tell from the
season 1 episodes every time he's done
that he's done it instinctively the
force choking thing was a little bit
different because of the way he was
twirling his tiny little hands and
fingers around making tiny little fists
you don't really see human babies get
that elaborate and dramatic with their
poses if he were at the same level
developmentally as a human baby he would
just start kicking and screaming and
flailing his arms all over the place the
motions that Baby Yoda was making during this are the
same that you might see an older version
of Yoda during the original trilogy
making implying that he's a lot smarter
than he seems
number six another easy prediction to
make the armorer said that some of the
Mandalorians former clan members in the
covert here may have escaped before the
Imperials came back and killed these
mandos that's probably a teaser that
we'll see a few them pop up around the
galaxy in future seasons when they go to
other planets in the outer rim it just
to be clear even though these ones were
killed off there are still little
pockets of Mandalorians like this all
over the outer rim planets hiding out
after the great purge so I think it's
implied that there's still at least a
couple hundred or even a couple thousand
still left alive after the great purge
just scattered all over the galaxy just
waiting for someone to rally them to
rise up again if only there was a
Mandalorian character out there using
something that the older Mandalorians
used as a totem to rally around him you
know what could you actually use is a
signal to rally all the Mandalorians
together number five obviously I'm
talking about the darksaber if you
never watched the animated Clone Wars
series or Star Wars rebels the darksaber was used by the Mandalorians in
ancient times as a symbol to rally
around in unite all their warring clans
together under a single banner right now Moff Gideon has it it's implied that
he stole it sometime during the Great
Purge on Mandalore during the course of
the original trilogy of course I think
they'll let Pedro pascal's Mandalorian
character play with it at some point on
screen but I don't expect him to steal
it back from Moff Gideon permanently
during season two seriously if we're
talking about video game mechanics here
like it's a bit of a fetch quest series
where he goes around collecting bounties
so that he can pay for upgrades to his
armor the darksaber is like the
legendary drop that you get after one of
the big final bosses in your final raid
encounters if the show runs four or five
seasons they would probably save
something like the Mandalorian wielding
the darksaber on a regular basis for
one of the final seasons but the mando
got his jetpack upgrade at the end of
season one darksaber upgrade obviously
off in the distance there's got to be
some other upgrades that he will acquire
during season two so number four next
big armor upgrade he's probably going to
get and it's actually a pretty easy
upgrade is just to get more larger
rockets that he can fire out of his
jetpack larger than the whistling birds
that he carries in his gauntlets because a lot
of the weapons that he has are inspired
by Boba Fett's weapons in the original
trilogy and there's still a couple
weapons they haven't done from the
animated Clone Wars series and Star Wars
rebels that those Mandalorians used and
because it's Star Wars
obviously Star Wars trades a lot on the
trope of super weapons the arc pulse
generator was a Mandalorian designed
weapon but it was used against
Mandalorians during the animated series
they could introduce some stuff like
that eventually to right now the only
super weapon that we know about on the
show that the villain obviously Moff
Gideon wants to acquire is baby Yoda he
is literally the super weapon that he
wants to use to take over the galaxy
again so number three will probably also
learn the exact nature of Moff Gideon
and dr. Pershing's cloning plans for
baby Yoda and how they intend on using
his power and his DNA to create an army
of force-sensitive clones
it was also implied that Moff Gideon
plans to use baby Yoda himself like a
weapon exploiting him as he grows up
possibly turning him to the darkside of
the force in the process because if you
abused someone like that over a long
course of time they would also fall to
the dark side to probably wind up
killing you and everyone around them but
then going on a tear and turning into
someone just as bad as Emperor Palpatine
best example that was that funny scene
at the beginning of episode 8 with the
scout troopers they both punched baby
Yoda which is almost an unforgivable act
but baby Oda literally bit one of them
on the finger so if you mistreat him he
will literally and metaphorically come
back to bite you
I'm really hoping though that we get to
see inside the actual imperial
facilities that Moff Gideon is using in
that he controls like inside their
Imperial version of the cloning facility
because of all the implied cloning stuff
does going on in this series they might
also bring back some Kamino ends from
the prequels as part of this plot we
only know a little bit about what
happened to their people in the planet
Kamino after the prequels it was
recorded officially that the Emperor
shut down the cloning facility on Kamino
after revenge of the sith but clearly we
know that that's a lie and that wasn't
the end of his cloning experiments from
the events of rise of Skywalker number
two this is actually a pretty big one
the Lucasfilm people revealed that we'd
see more classic characters from the
original trilogy Skywalker saga during
season two I'm trying to temper my
expectations for what that will look
like people
that they're doing classic characters
from the movies and immediately they
start thinking about Luke Skywalker into
really big characters but the only
version of Luke Skywalker that's
actually been rumored to appear on any
of the Disney Plus shows is a very very
young little kid version of Luke during
the events of the obi-wan Kenobi's
series on Tatooine and he'd only be
around 10 or 11 years old at best well
that's happening even though sebastian
stan is probably waiting by his phone on
the set of Falcon and Winter Soldier
waiting for that call to play adult Luke
Skywalker no joke he actually looks like
Mark Hamill's son in real life he really
does look like a young version of Luke
so if they ever did do adult Luke that
was not Mark Hamill he would be perfect
for that so when they say original
trilogy characters will be appearing
during season two I'm mostly just
expecting Bounty Hunter characters
because even though the show is really
about what's going on with baby Yoda
there's supposed to be a lot of bounty
hunting happening during the series so
it just makes sense if he's a bounty
hunter he would run into other classic
bounty hunters who are still alive in
number one prediction this is also a
pretty easy one to we'll see new rogue
Jedi and force sensitive characters on
the show they're looking for the Jedi
that survived the purge that's one of
the armourers edicts to him go find
other Jedi to train him enemies
sorcerers is what they called them on
the TV show which I thought was
hilarious there's that special religious
organization centered around the force I
think the Church of the force that
appears during the course of the new
trilogy in Jedi trainees who failed to
complete their training before the purge
happened there was even a storyline
during season six of the Clone Wars
where there was a holocron that the Jedi
had with the names of a bunch of
force-sensitive children all over the
galaxy that had yet to be contacted by
the Jedi and brought into the Jedi
Temple for formal Jedi training that
could still be alive in present day so I
don't know they're going to introduce any
kind of holocrons or anything like that
but there's still a lot of force
sensitive children from the original
trilogy in prequel era that because of
the purge never went through Jedi
training but would still be alive in
present day and still be force sensitive
but I'm not expecting you at all to show
up suddenly or Yoda's force ghost or
anything like that I think most of the
force sensitive characters that they
introduced on the show will be
completely brand new characters that
we've never seen before because if you
think about it the show has already
proven that it doesn't need major movie
characters to appear
in order for the show to be popular it's
already crazy huge with just baby Yoda
and the mandalorian who are two brand
new characters that we never saw before
this series what that allows them to do
is use the TV show to world build and
because there's not going to be any more
Star Wars movies for a while the Disney
Plus series will be responsible for
expanding the Star Wars universe in
order to do that you have to introduce
new characters everyone let me know in
the comments though which new rogue Jedi or deep cut force sensitive characters
from the expanded universe do you want
them to introduce on the show or bring
back into the Canon but I will keep
doing Mandalorian videos throughout the
year we're probably going to get a trailer
sometime by the summer because they're
almost done filming season two right now
they're well into doing their season two
episodes so it shouldn't be that long
before we get some more teasers
congratulations seal phantom you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Star
Wars video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details everyone click here for my Mandalorian
season 2 teaser in episode 8 ending
scene and click here for all my Witcher
Netflix episode videos with Henry Cavill
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome happy new year!